the yes/no ratio for us was probably for
other people who did get back to us was
probably about a third people said yes
food you would know better the rank as
you handled it all um so there was a lot
of research that led to nothing because
people didn't want to not get paid which
is but you give it a min you get people
that say well okay we'll waive it and if
you get in baby would you be willing to
pay the fee if you get in so we say yes
to that or would you be willing to you
know pay half or would you be willing to
draw a picture of what you think I look
like yeah that was like that was an
actual one yeah wait at the if you draw
a picture what you think I look like I
really thought we were in on that one
yeah it was pretty good picture they
were being sarcastic no they wanted to
but then they didn't actually I was like
I think it was his project for the year
or anyone who asked for a fee I ever do
that so they'd have all these like are
doing it himself how does wall I don't
think yeah it was fun oh good so then
did you consider okay what if I actually
do get into this festival how am I going
to get there we haven't been able to go
to a lot of them which is unfortunate it
would be great to go anywhere ever
movies playing and then a lot of them
was just out of our pocket or they would
pay for a hotel or they play pay for my
ticket um so that way if we were going
together we would splurge on a second
ticket and you know pay our own pocket
yeah so it's been really expensive yeah
mmmm any tips on q and A's afterwards
like what are some of the do's and
don'ts besides asking don't ask what you
shot on don't have well those are things
people do ask
and um and it's easy cuz we shot on the
red and no one knows what that means
that they go and her arse peel for the
reason why we can't tell how much the
movie costs is be explained how it
affects distribution when people know
and and you know that's what all
filmmakers want to know and everyone
else wants to know is how much it costs
and we really can't tell you and this is
why I and I think explaining why helps
well usually we open with a joke they
say how much does it cost we say a
hundred million dollars but we spend
most food on the catering father's right
yeah and uh actually a lot of the Q&A
questions are exactly the same so once
you've done a couple easy you felt you'd
figure out what your stock answers are
right um the do's and don'ts uh speaking
it clear voice I guess and know how to
use a microphone okay there are some
really interesting moderators wasn't
someone who I love to them I loved one
um the woman wouldn't let me hold the
microphone and so I was I'd be fine
running the Q&A myself but she she
wanted to do it and so and she would
hold it like this and I was like I miss
talking to people and so that was lovely
cute yeah just was her time as her mic
right
you